CEL stars john cusack and samuel
l.jackson is based off of the Stephen
King novel now this isn't one of his
best novels he is my favorite writer but
even when you're reading okay King
you're reading a good book on top of
that a movie called 1408 that also stars
John Cusack and samuel l.jackson is
based off of a Stephen King short story
and this is a fairly underrated thriller
it's not amazing but it has a few
moments and I enjoyed it overall so when
I found out they were teaming up again
to do another Stephen King adaptation I
was actually really anticipating this
movie and it went straight to Amazon
video it's going to be I guess in some
theaters in July but I rented it for 48
hours for $9.99 on Amazon video and I'm
so glad I did what's this one about
so John Cusack is at an airport and all
of a sudden people around him start
going insane they start frothing at the
mouth they're running around people are
killing each other they're screaming
they're laughing they're dancing they're
jumping and all of it seems to be coming
from people's cell phones and for
whatever reason this cell phone
transmission is affecting the population
and people are turning into sort of a
variation of a zombie they're running
around they're killing people and it's
all being transmitted through some sort
of cell phone signal and cusack runs
into jackson and they team up because
they're normal they meet a young girl
played by isabelle fuhrman i believe you
say her name that way she was the very
good actress from the movie orphan and
these people attempt to find their loved
ones or people they care about because
everyone else is insane because of
cellphones okay how do I get into this
when I saw norm of the North earlier
this year I was positive that I had seen
the worst film of the year I didn't
think I'd ever see anything that could
possibly give it competition until this
morning when I sat down on my couch and
watched sell this film is incredibly
horrible I mean there is so much shit in
this movie it's so so bad why is it bad
well it's technically incompetent on
almost every level I think every scene
was handheld the editing is
incomprehensible bad there are so many
sequences that are so scatterbrained and
jumbled and convoluted that you can't
follow a thorough line of a story in
this movie john cusack wants to find his
family that's it
and in between his journey we're going
to have laugh out loud hilariously bad
shitty shaky-cam sequences with these
zombie guys they call phoners jumping
around and going like I'm not making
this up guys it is absolutely
astonishingly bad I laughed so much in
this film it was hilarious 4 mini
portions and then it gets dreadfully
boring I'm talking painful the first act
of this movie every time some sort of
attack happened from one of these zombie
things I screeched with laughter I'm not
kidding during the airport sequence it
cuts to this guy he's just going like
I'm not making it up I fucking broke
down with laughter it's incredible and
some of the violence is so over-the-top
and fake-looking
that it's just sad to be honest it's sad
the attempts at CGI actually hurt
there's a sequence near the end of the
film where a whole bunch of people are
walking in a circle and way too many
people for this film's budget clearly so
they kept digitally reinserting the same
person at various points during the
sequence I counted three of the exact
same person in one shot it's that bad i
streamed this through Amazon video on my
4k television as I said legally 9.99 I
payed for this bullshit and on my 4k TV
the green screen was so horrific Lee
atrociously noticeable it stung my eyes
to even look at especially during the
ending sequence which no spoilers don't
worry if you want to see this thing go
ahead you might actually have a great
time watching this movie because it is
so hilariously bad during many sequences
and I actually think this movie might be
one of those movies that gets that type
of reputation you know people were like
have you seen cell you never seen cell
dude you got a watch so it's so fucking
awful and amazing you just got to watch
it but let me get back to what I was
taught
about no spoilers this ending it's what
I mean my mouth dropped I wasn't just
shocked by the incredible ambiguity of
it all about how literally everything is
open to interpretation I wasn't just
shocked by that I was shocked by how
technically horrible everything looks
about the way this film ends it is
honestly like somebody got a green
screen somebody found John Cusack on the
street somebody opened up Adobe After
Effects for the very first time with a
computer in attempted to make a movie
it's that bad I'm not exaggerating this
movie's a disaster in every way this is
sad on the level of it's a team up of
actors who were in another good Stephen
King adaptation before John Cusack
actually was in stand by me as well so
this is his third Stephen King
adaptation it's at as an adaptation of
Kings book it's sad because Stephen King
apparently took part in writing the
screenplay but I did a little research
really quick before I film this video
and John Cusack said on his Twitter that
him and Stephen King were both cut out
of this film in the long run in other
words they had nothing to do with the
post-production process of this movie
and I'm not surprised because there's a
minute and 20 seconds of production
companies at the beginning of this movie
a minute and 20 seconds I paused it just
to see the time frame because I was like
that's an absurd amount of production
company's a minute and a half of
production company logos it's between
this and no more the north right now
this is one of the most hilariously bad
new releases I've seen in a long time
and very disappointing I'm gonna give
sell an F if you feel like supporting
them it's $10 on Amazon video right now
or not you know life is short so I
wouldn't waste it like I did watching
sell guys thank you so much as always
for watching my god if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes